[Music]
foreign
Texas a rural community 90 miles north
of Dallas people have to travel to get
to the doctor and that's difficult for a
lot of people here and it's time
consuming there's no public
transportation nor is there any ride
sharing available so we stayed open
throughout the pandemic so people could
come here because people didn't have
computers or Internet subscriptions at
home then we started getting a couple
calls from people who wanted to have
doctor's appointments libraries are
perfectly positioned to work with with
Telehealth because we're oftentimes the
fastest internet connection in town
people trust Librarians it's a neutral
space
we're accustomed to helping people with
digital literacy skills so it all came
together to
request funding mean to start a virtual
health room here the original proposal
that they pitched was to create a pilot
Telehealth site that would allow them to
figure out best practices that they
could distribute as a model to other
libraries or other community
organizations that are looking to do the
same thing and in that respect it has
been the resounding success a crucial
partner in this was also HSC Health
which is sort of the clinical support
that they got for managing schedules for
setting up appointments with providers
so as it stands right now there are 77
counties that don't have a hospital
telemedicine can be a real solution to a
lot of these problems if we have both
the equipment and then you have to have
someone special there to help lead the
way and to acknowledge that it's
actually safe
nnlm made it possible for us to convert
this old storage room filled with old
books into
a virtual Health ring a room where
people can come in connect with health
care providers get the care they need
closer to home it's leading to people
being healthier during covid I did not
want to go sit in a doctor's office and
expose myself
to bigger things when I just had a minor
health issue so this made it to where I
my safety came first and it was Private
easy convenient that's why I chose it
it's a great model and in fact we've
created a Playbook because this is not
about Secret Sauce this is about let's
make our communities healthier here's
what we learned from this experience and
here's what we wish we had done a little
bit differently how fabulous would it be
if all rural communities had this kind
of access healthy people become Healthy
Communities whenever Pottsboro Texas is
on national news I know we've done
something worthwhile and I am proud of
being the first pioneer to do this to be
able to help other libraries across the
country make this happen and it's a
reality now that would not have happened
without nnlm